heizen sammeln wir haben heute einfach
eine riesengroße ankündigung wenn nicht
sogar die größte ankündigung seit
erstellung unseres youtube kanals sollte
ohne job blog ist seit dem online
shopper genau das ist ein projekt der
arbeiten hier im hintergrund seit einem
jahr dran also exakt seit einem jahr und
jetzt ist so ein moment wo wir das
einfach verkünden dürfen vom herzen
fällt
sie sind aufgeregt genau im ropac ja was
machen wir jetzt hier und wir verkünden
wir dass wir unser eigenes café eröffnen
[Musik]
die bombe ist geplatzt ist und weshalb
auch heftig ist gelungen zwei jahren
sagt die community wann machst du deinen
kaffee aber es ist nicht die frage mich
nur wie macht ihr das café soll ja alles
oder dann macht er so ein schaf das will
zweite platz machen kam ok also ist es
noch nicht geklärt es ist kein druck
drauf ist es keine werbe drauf aber der
laden wird bald die sketchen helfen und
das coole ist ihr habt nur zwei meter
vom café das heißt dass an effect 2 1
ihr habt da leckereien und screens und
alles drum und dran also der laden mit
quasi auch kiki sketchen werden und da
könnt ihr dann in riekofen backform
springt von
1958 gibt alles schwarzkümmelöl alles
was sie im shop haben kommt da rein und
da könnt ihr
jede woche hier einmal mindestens ich
würde wahrscheinlich auch erst jetzt
kommen ich hoffe auch dass ich nicht ein
paar kilo zunehmen weil ich jetzt sofort
verstehen warum mache ich auch hier ob
programmstunden alles drum und dran
hätte ich noch mehr sogar ein video hier
gedacht und an der stelle noch mal alle
haben uns abgeraten alle sagen und wie
kann man vom online-handel in den
stationären handel wie ihr seid doch
gefeiert aber die einzigen die lange
geglaubt haben die unity gewesen das ist
unvermeidlich
ihr habt so möglich ihr wollte das so
genau sondern alle die jetzt einfach so
einen er schon sind oder mal den rumpf
besichtigen möchten haben noch ein
cooles gewünscht wie ihr seht ihr unser
herz unserer kiki screen
voll gut organisiert auf jeden fall wir
uns überlegt dass wenn ihr einfach ein
foto schießt hier vor dem herz sowie
haben sich aber machen schöne pozo mein
okay es ist auch immer könnt ihr dann
jede woche einen 50 euro gutschein was
müsst ihr tun einfach das photon
entkommen das war genau ein foto
schießen kurzvideo bumerang machen ist
jede woche bis zur eröffnung und
wahrscheinlich also wir planen ist
wahrscheinlich im juni spätestens das
ist schon das ist
das ist die dafür tun
die leute die jetzt nicht entweder
wurden für dieses natürlich dass mir das
stimmt wie gehen wir aus drei gutscheine
den können wir jetzt auch 350 euro gut
seine kommentare in welcher stadt
eröffnen wir diese zwei leben genau und
dann nehmt ihr automatisch teil und die
gewinner werden dann auf jeden fall
unter dem video verkündet und jetzt noch
eine sache wir brauchen natürlich auch
weil wir suchen mitarbeiter für den
standort hier ja ich sage jetzt nicht
das weiß man ja gewinnspiel ja schon auf
jeden fall schreibt bitte gerne eine
werbung an bewerbung epic ist kicker.de
ist ein gewährt wie häufig suchen am
besten vielleicht barista für mich hätte
menschen die bock haben für den shop
fürs café die einfach ein teil des teams
werden möchten teil der
bewerber gibt heute gerne bewerben führt
die würfel oder für den shop je nachdem
ob die erfahrungen im gastrobereich habe
die erfahrungen genau geschäften oder
wissen deutlich auch in der nähe kommen
nicht aus frankfurt also wir hoffen die
zwei bomben überraschungen sind gelebt
wir freuen uns auf eure kommentare wir
freuen uns auf das projekt film
natürlich auch ein bisschen was mit und
bin einfach nur gefühlschaos die unten
ich bin einfach nur aufgeregt
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]